always confident at times defensive
as the incumbent u.s president donald
trump now has a record to pick apart
and he got a grilling starting out with
the nation's biggest crisis
the coronavirus i knew it was a big
threat
at the same time i don't want to panic
this country
i don't want to go out and say
everybody's going to die everybody
you don't have to mislead but you can no
no no there's not a middle ground
and more contentious exchanges as trump
made exaggerated claims about voter
fraud
and deflected criticism over his tax
returns and his position on white
supremacy
you've done this to me and everybody
seemed like i denounced
white supremacy okay
at the same time on a different channel
a different tone
trump's challenger joe biden offered a
forceful rebuke of trump's pandemic
response
it is a presidential responsibility to
lead and he didn't do that he didn't
talk about what
needed to be done because he kept
worrying in my view
about the stock market we make up four
percent of the world's population we
have 20 percent of the world's deaths
we're in a situation where we have 210
plus thousand people
dead and what's he doing nothing he's
still
not wearing masks and so on at times
biden meandered
but he did deliver clear punchlines on a
number of issues including foreign
policy
if they vote out before the election you
are open we've been most effective
as a world leader in my humble opinion
not just
by the exercise of our power the most
powerful nation in the world
but the power of our example that's
what's led
the rest of the world to follow us after
trading blows remotely
the two candidates will again face off
at the final election debate
next week our washington correspondent
other person
had one eye on each event and joins us
now oliver
what stood out for you in these parallel
appearances
well it was a lot more sophisticated
terry than
the first presidential debate and it
seemed like this new
format the town hall works better for
joe biden so trump in turn he made a lot
of
false claims during this conversation
and the host there at the network that
broadcast
this town hall nbc challenged president
trump grilled him essentially over a
variety of questions
and and topics and simply he did not
look good
defending himself he did not look good
debating
at certain points he didn't want to
remember or didn't know
certain details so biden in turn had a
rather
solid appearance then came across a lot
more presidential
as someone who is really willing and
able also to heal
the nation that is very divided right
now of course and he was able to deliver
his points much better
that worked out than during the first
debate that ended in chaos
now the original plan oliver was for the
two candidates to have another
face-to-face debate how did things end
up
this way
well first of all as you remember
president trump tested positive
on uh covet 19 and then the prayer the
commission
of on presidential debates that's
usually in charge of
organizing these debates then decided to
hold a
virtual debate so both candidates in
different locations
in order to avoid the risk or to reduce
the risk of infection now
president trump backed out saying he was
not willing to participate at a virtual
debate then the debate was cancelled and
then the biden campaign moved forward
scheduling
this town hall event and it was just one
day earlier so on wednesday
that president trump and nbc the network
decided or announced
they would hold a dueling event just at
the same time and of course
both receiving lots of criticism for
that move because again it left the
voters here in limbo
they had to decide if they either wanted
to see president trump or joe biden
oliver thank you very much dw's oliver
solid there in washington
for some more analysis let's bring in
tyson barker he's a fellow at the truman
national security project and is based
here in berlin good to see you tyson so
this election is special in many ways
but particularly in that we have a large
number of early voters and a small
number of undecided voters
given that can these public appearances
or debates make much of a difference
i i think they can definitely make a
difference i mean what we have seen is a
surge in early voting
uh caused primarily by the pandemic and
the president's statements uh
questioning the integrity of elections
uh by mail so many people are going to
the polls
early to make sure that they can avoid
those lines given the social distancing
um
necessity but you know they're the the
bulk of voting is still going to take
place that weekend and probably on that
that tuesday so you know there are still
people watching
this is when people really tune in about
two weeks out before the election so
there's a whole swath
of the voter uh poppy voting population
that haven't really been watching
okay and we've got one more debate it
must be said coming up next week well
one of the key moments from trump's
appearance was his refusal to disavow
the
q anon conspiracy theory can you tell us
a bit more about that
well in in disa well he basically said i
don't know
i don't know what it is i don't know
what it's about i heard it's about
pedophilia that's all i know so he
basically tries to distance himself by
pleading
ignorance that is a tactic that he tried
to use as well
in 2016 when he was endorsed by former
ku klux klan uh grand wizard david duke
uh david duke said this is our guy uh
although trump was on the record in the
80s having spoken about david duke
basically denouncing him he said in the
2016 election i don't know who he is i
don't know what's happening
and uh savannah guthrie the moderator
basically interrupted him and said in
real time what we all thought which is
you can't be serious you know what this
organization is you know what they're
about
biden continues to lead in the polls how
is that
affecting the campaign strategies both
of the republicans and the democrats
uh you know it's
it's still a little worrisome for
everybody because we don't know how many
say hidden uh trump voters there are how
many hidden biden voters there are what
the role of voter turnout's going to
play
this election is taking place on ground
that neither candidate is really
familiar with
on the one hand you have a very
energized electorate which usually means
higher voter turnout but on the other
hand there's this overlay of the the
pandemic
so uh the polls especially the national
polls which don't really
say much because this is an election
that takes place in 50 states
simultaneously for
uh electoral college votes for these
points that they can win win or take all
in each state
um but it has been a pretty stable lead
but at the same time some of these polls
reflect uh the
same kind of polling we were seeing in
2016 so it's still kind of an open race
tyson thank you so much that was tyson
barker from the truman
national security project thank you
let's bring in our fact checker here
joshua weber joshua
trump made some claims about the at his
appearance last night let's start
with a clip on that as far as the mask
is concerned i'm good with masks i'm
okay with masks i tell people wear mess
but just the other day they came out
with a statement that 85 percent of the
people that wear masks catch it
so they did it i know that study that's
what i heard and that's what i saw
85 percent of people who wear masks get
the coronavirus uh joshua
what is trump referring to and is this
correct
well president trump is again referring
to a study of the u.s center for disease
control and prevention the cdc from
september
and he said this before and basically
it's a misinterpretation of this study
what it found out was that among those
persons who tested positive for the
coronavirus
85 percent said that they were wearing a
mask always often yes
but the study also found out that for
those persons that had tested negative
89 reported they were wearing a mask the
cdc even clarified after trump's earlier
claims on that
that this claim was misleading and
incorrect
in addition the study only followed 314
people a very small sample we have to
say
the results so cannot be generalized so
we don't know why president trump
repeatedly makes this meeting misleading
claim about the cdc study
and there are so many more studies that
prove face marks
are slowing down the spread of the
coronavirus
okay trump had more to say on the
handling of the corona
crisis on his handling but he compared
the development of the case numbers in
the u.s with those
for europe let's take a listen the uk is
up two thousand five hundred percent
the eu's up 722 and the united states is
down
21 sounds good uh
is donald trump right with these numbers
on the coronavirus
no it's unclear where trump got the okay
figure from
or what metric or time frame he was
actually referring to
but indeed the uk has seen a rise in
covet
19 cases and deaths per day in the last
few weeks of course
during the last seven days the uk had
118 percent
more cases and 28 more
than compared to the last week following
the world health organization
so a sharp rise but not as high high as
trump said here
if we look to the u.s trump's numbers
aren't correct neither
if we look on the last seven days the
united states
had 11 more cases and equal dust
compared to the last week
so if it con comes to european union
trump did not say
where he got his figure from neither but
the european center of
disease prevention states an average
rise of 13
cases in europe so again we have to say
that trump's claim is misleading here
so playing fast and loose with the
numbers there uh joshua let's jump over
to joe biden he
held his town hall meeting at the same
time and made a number of claims here's
his remark
on the international standing of the u.s
for example
so i uh you know i would say we find
ourselves
less secure than we've been if you take
a look
we're not very well trusted around the
world when
17 major nations in the world were asked
who they trust more
who's the better leader and the
president came in behind
both the national survey international
survey
both behind putin as well as
she so he joe biden they're referring to
a ranking
is this true yoshi well first when asked
by an audience member whether trump's
foreign policy deserved some credit joe
biden said
sure a little but then quickly claimed
that the u.s are more isolated than ever
before and if we measure this
with this trustworthiness we can say
that biden's claim is somewhat
true according to a poor research survey
published in september
only 16 percent of people in the 13 not
as claimed 17 countries
uh were soviet uh that uh trump do the
right thing
china she received 19 and russia's putin
23
so trump is behind them and but it's not
only trump
trust uh in the us as a whole has
declined
uh over the past few weeks and the the
whole year actually the same survey
found out
in the uk and france a record low of
only
41 and 31 of people
respectively expressed a federal opinion
of the us
and in germany it's only 26 for
the us another topic
at the town hall meeting with joe biden
was the future of energy
here's a claim from biden on fracking
well first of all
i make it clear i do not propose
banning fracking i think you have to
make sure that fracking is in fact
not emitting methane or polluting the
well
or dealing with what can be
small earthquakes and how they're
drilling so it has to be
managed very very well number one
joshua is biden making any making any
claims there that can be challenged
well he's not completely false here we
have to say
but and he seems to be clear in this
point but this is at odds with his
own running mate uh vice presidential
candidate kamala harris has stated
previously that
she is in favor of banning fracking she
has since
reversed her position but joe biden's
website said
that he wishes to ban new permits from
being issued
for fracking and wants to gradually move
away from fracking
so this is at least a bit confusing for
me
what he actually wants at this point
thank you so much joshua that was our
fact checker
yahshua vapor in both
let's get some more analysis now peter
willardo
from our u.s elections team is with us
good morning good morning
so what have we learned from all of this
well i think if anything this
has really illustrated you know how deep
the division in america is it does feel
sometimes
like this election has felt like you
know parents going through a really ugly
divorce and now they're
you know arguing over who's the worst
parent and who gets to keep the kids
in front of their children i mean this
is essentially what what this has felt
like a lot you know there's a complete
absence of willingness
to even engage in a meaningful
in in civilized dialogue with the other
side and i think
having these two parallel dueling
debates
really i think underscores that um you
know i will say that
before the debate there was obviously a
lot of criticism of
especially nbc's decision to run the
debate at the same time
that we saw the the biden debate but
i think what a lot of that criticism is
justified it also felt like these
in a sense worked a bit like a
microscope it really magnified the
strengths and weaknesses
of each candidate uh biden felt calm
and pathetic uh mostly stuff with facts
he was a bit meandering
even a bit rambling at times but you
know for those longing for
you know the old school type of politics
um
you know pre-trump i think they will
probably left
uh feeling a bit warm and fussy after
seeing this
trump at the same time also really show
why his supporters love him i mean
he's tested he fights back he may have a
loose relationship with truth
but you know he's a master of making
everything happen on his terms
the problem with that is just to get to
the final point though is to you know
a lot of americans won't have the chance
to look through
that proverbial microscope they don't
have the time they're busy worrying
about the economy they're busy worrying
about how to put their
kids through school how to stay safe
during a pandemic where
nearly 8 million americans have been
affected 220 000 almost have been killed
and so
this town hall felt you know it's
supposed to be the essence of democratic
debate and it really felt
undemocratic in the sense that it was a
disservice to the american voter i think
do you think these appearances or
debates even matter in this particular
election
given the large number of early voters
and the
small number of undecided voters yeah
historically debates
happen when most americans really start
paying attention to
the election uh as you mentioned they're
we're we're seeing huge numbers of early
voting
um 20 million is a number of hurts yeah
i think well
20 or 17 18 it's it's in the high double
digits uh
and and so you know at the same time
we're seeing fairly low levels of
undecided voters so
it suggests that after four years of
trump you know a lot of americans have
made up their minds how they feel about
him
the reality is also though i mean think
back to 2016
the election is not decided by the
popular vote it really comes down to
electoral college the 270 votes that you
need to get there
and especially we're looking at about
eight key swing states
biden is leading in almost all of them
he has a double-digit lead nationally
and he's leading among every demographic
group
peter thank you so much uh peter
rolandale from our u.s elections team
thank you